La idea es que esta nueva Norma aclare
expresiones confusas y ambiguas que
tenía la legislación inicial Cuáles son
esas ambigüedades y cuál es el alcance
que tendría la aplicación de esta Norma
Buenas noches
el gobernador de Santos y la cámara de
la Florida han expandido la ley no digas
que a todos los niveles de grado pero
eso es algo que ellos dijeron que no
iban a hacer cuando primero pasó esta
ley esta ley fue pasada con el vale de
que iba a darle más poder a los padres
para los padres poder proteger a sus
hijos y lo que ellos aprendieran en las
escuelas pero lo que ha hecho este
gobierno es eliminar libros limitar la
educación sobre los temas sociales y
atacar a niños que simplemente quieren
aprender Y ser suyo auténtico y tanto la
norma inicial como la extensión Por más
que el Gobernador republicano de santis
dijera que no lo iba a hacer
originalmente Sí fue promovida por él
Esto hace parte de su impulso para la
posible precandidatura presidencial
Claro que sí claro que sí es una
vergüenza ver lo que está haciendo y lo
que está pensando que podría que si él
puede se hace presidente este esta
arriesga que
las personas lgbt se han borradas a un
nivel nacional lo curioso es que sabe
cuando estas leyes fueron pasadas ellos
trataron de pasarlo como como ser
republicanos para el partido republicano
es un partido que dice que no se quiere
meter en las en las en la familia no se
quiere meter en las escuelas no quiere
meter ninguno de esos lugares quiere ser
un partido de un gobierno pequeño pero
lo que han hecho es expandir la
presencia del gobierno en todas las
partes de la vida de todo el mundo aquí
en la Florida y si él se hace presidente
Eso sí él lo va a querer hacer en un en
un en una locación nacional también aquí
pero ese impulso no es solo del
gobernador de santis y de hecho de
manera paralela a la cámara Estatal de
Florida aprobó un proyecto de ley para
convertir en delito grave
que se brinde atención médica para
quienes quieran afirmar su género siendo
menores de edad transgénero A qué se
debe esta ola de medidas que limita los
derechos de las personas
lgbtiq más en el estado
sabes es una forma de control ellos
quieren controlar y quieren
ponerle atención a cosas que no deben
poner la atención y en vez de arreglar
los problemas que verdad tenemos en este
país en ese estado
la verdad es que no es nada Mala Florida
es el estado de Texas el estado de
Tennessee el estado de Georgia muchos
estados que son aquí se llaman los
estados rojos que fueron lo que lo que
siempre lo que siempre están con el
expresidente Trump han pasado leyes que
que han
tratado de de eliminar y borrar las
personas lgbt y eso no está bien y tú te
tienes que preguntar por qué siguen este
ataque cuando la mayoría de las personas
en este país en los Estados Unidos ya ya
se han movido de de esa forma de pensar
eso eso es una cosa que la más Piensa la
mayoría del país aquí en los Estados
Unidos